millas machine learning applied research team
is
closed of more than fifteen to do
5 they are high caliber researchers
who have specialized either in
machine learning or
related fields including a physical
the work of
2009 applied research team well understand the
problem of the company has
given itself to see what is the dribble of the
research and the rsta can be used
to solve this problem and creates
value for the entry in several months
a year  but for more than a year we are going to
work hand in hand with a
technical team in a company
to carry out an applied project it is
the concentration of the expertise of
researchers of the highest level in the world
who are there to help companies
to guide them if a  company wants to
stand out today it needs
to innovate and place and in the
essential cars of
[Music]